all right guys I'm gonna be completely
honest with you I never thought I'd have
a robot vacuum in my own home but now we
have two kids keeping my wife and I
busier than I ever thought we'd be so
when verepa reached out to sponsor this
video I thought what the heck let's try
it out and now two weeks later I'm
actually surprised by how well it works
as well as how inexpensive the V60 Pro
really is making it the best value auto
emptying Robot vacuum I've ever seen and
what I mean by Auto emptying is that it
comes with an automatic dust collection
system which usually costs a lot of
extra cash if you look at some of the
other big brand names and this one is
even more compact using up less space
the way it works is that the V60 Pro
vacuum goes around vacuuming dust and
debris and then when it's done cleaning
it returns to the base station which
then automatically vacuums the debris
out of the robot itself through an air
duct product on the back which hasn't
clogged on me once just listen to how it
works
and if you're wondering wondered where
all of it goes just lift up this lid to
reveal an easily disposable bag which
Auto seals to not spread dust collecting
up to 30 days of dust and then swap it
out with another one which by the way
the V60 Pro comes with two extra bags in
the Box as well as an extra air filter
and spin brush now as far as charging
the robot vacuum comes with these two
metal contact pads that perfectly align
with the ones on the base station and
it's worked like a charm every single
time and moving on to the most important
thing of all the actual cleaning
performance I was pleasantly surprised
by the zigzag cleaning path which
basically makes it so it doesn't miss
any areas by going back and forth in
straight lines and on top of that the
obstacle avoidance with its Optical path
sensor navigation works extremely well
with this bumper system that kind of
makes it recoil back without damaging
anything and then it quickly reverses in
spins to get out of a tough area without
getting stuck now one thing that
pleasantly surprised me was that no
matter which room it was in it always
knew the way back to the base station
when it finished cleaning or needed to
charge up again and by the way the
battery life was great with up to two
hours of non-stop battery life more than
I needed for my entire floor I was also
surprised that it was able to easily
climb and move over certain objects that
stick out from the floor like for
example the vent on the floor or are
welcome mat next to the door it moved
over them without any issues at all and
that's partly because of the
self-adjusting floating brush roll
system that adjusts to the surface that
it's cleaning for better contact making
it do a great job at picking up debris
and hair with its integrative cleaning
system just look at this pile of hair it
picked up the first time it cleaned just
one room apps absolutely doing a great
job and it was so easy to clean off of
the brush roll since you just pushed
these two pins and the brush roll is
free to come out for cleaning and then
what's really awesome is that they
actually include this little cleaning
comb on the bottom of the Dust box which
can help you easily cut through all of
the hair and get rid of it but what
really blew me away was when I came in
and checked out my kids's room to find
the most clean and straight vacuum lines
I've ever seen and those lines are all
due to the fact that this Robot vacuum
supports the auto boost function which
automatically senses and detects when
it's on carpet and it increases the
suction to up to 2700 pascals so it
vastly exceeded my expectations for
carpet cleaning now you won't believe
this but the V60 Pro runs so quietly
that I actually had it clean their
entire room at night while both of my
kids were sleeping and yes 9 either of
them woke up and that's not even using
the quiet mode which produces noise as
low as 58 decibels so because of that I
ended up scheduling the robot to clean
up every night right before midnight
without worrying about them waking up
and I did it using the app which I'll
get into in just a minute after I talk
about my number one favorite feature
because of the very slim profile it was
actually able to vacuum under both of
their beds and even my own king-sized
bed with ease which is something that
would be literally impossible without a
robot vacuum like this which helps
collect and stop long-term dust buildup
under the bed now one thing I really
like is that you have a variety of
options in terms of controlling the
robot the first one is to use the
physical buttons on the top which
include the auto clean and pause button
the home button which makes it go back
to the base station and the spot clean
button which literally allows you to
place it on a pile of debris making it
clean in a circular spiral which is
really cool now another method of
control is the physical remote which
comes in the box and it includes even
more buttons like arrow keys and believe
it or not there's actually a remote
control feature built into the app which
gives you complete manual control
straight from your iPhone's display but
the method of control I like the best is
of course within the app itself giving
you all of those same buttons and extra
ones like Auto empty dirt and suction
power settings so you can manually turn
it up all the way if you want to to set
up the app simply install it from the
App Store create your account and hit
the pair button which happens
automatically if the vacuum is within
range and Bam you're in giving you a
really cool animation of what your robot
vac is currently doing going into the
settings there's a bunch of things you
can customize including the volume of
the robot the find my robot button which
will play a sound if you can't find it
the scheduling settings the consumables
and maintenance settings which lets you
know when to replace the filter and
other components and you even have
access to the cleaning records showing
you a detailed map including the time it
cleaned for and total surface area
cleaned so with all that said I've got
to say that this really is the best
value auto MTN Robot vacuum I've ever
seen because for 350 dollars even before
including the 60 off coupon on Amazon
it's less expensive than a lot of the
other name brand vacuum robots that
don't even come with a dust collection
system those ones are even more
expensive with worse suction power and
more bulky based stations so if you
consider the price the features and the
cleaning performance you really can't
beat the V60 Pro Robot vacuum in terms
of overall value now going into this I
honestly didn't expect a small and
compact Robot vacuum to actually have
enough suction power to create really
nice carpet lines but here we are and I
just love how you can set it up once and
never have to worry about it again since
it goes back to the base station
automatically whenever it finishes
cleaning or needs to recharge it just
works and it works well so if you're
interested in checking it out they
prepared an awesome Black Friday offer
for all of you guys so click the links
below to learn more once again thanks to
verifa for sponsoring this video and
making my life a lot easier at home if
you enjoyed this video click the circle
about to subscribe for more videos like
this one check out one of those two
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next one
[Music]
foreign